Some other non-functional issues which we've maybe alluded to but that
also play a role in dealing with these distributed heterogeneous application.
Include fault tolerance. How does the system deal with, let's say, exceptions
that arise. Flexibility, how to support, change in any of the components.
In general, you want to be able to support reuse. What that means is,
can you take some of the pieces, the components, and use them in
related applications? Thereby, improving your productivity. In general,
these applications can get quite complexed and they are often mission critical.
So you need to be able to manage that complexity. And fifth is quality service.
Quality of service or QOS is an, is a concept who's goal is to be able
to specifically measure the non-functional constraints. And
the extent to which the system deals with those. With performance, that's easy.
You can, you can measure the things like response time or throughput. But some
of the other non-functional considerations are harder to get a number around.